okay now here's here's my more
interesting food okay before I actually
get susan right and this is your made-up
in after I'm gone okay
I'm a kind of a unique spot we as a
class actually are a kind of a unique
spot in terms of where we are in
teaching the course what I mean is
because I started doing videos almost
exactly a year ago
okay actually just a bit over a year ago
and because I told you twelve this year
right and therefore started their HSE
cause into a philosophy right I actually
come full circle in terms of all the
topics that I've gone through okay so if
you stood among you will have noticed
that you know Susan sequences being our
next topic I actually already have a
playlist or Susan sequence of Eden took
like 20-something videos or somewhere
that and all the other topics there
because I taught them to you twelve last
year and this year right so I'm at a
unique spot in that I can do something
we as a class can do something different
okay now let me try to explain what's a
what's a normal how we normally do maths
as an all your work you come in I wait
for everyone to sort of arrive you
should get set up all that kind of thing
and then I'll give you like a short okay
sometimes short explanation of like a
concept or a technique that kind of
thing right maybe five to ten plus
minutes right and then what happens by
the time you've got a bit of time to do
some questions some exercises and then
the bill goes and then in theory you go
home and you finish that and that's how
we learn maths right okay
but there are two glaring problems with
that way of doing maths even though it's
basically the way that every high school
teacher does it number one
the explaining part right it's really
hard to do well here's what I mean if
I'm actually like if I've if I know what
I'm talking about right
then when I'm explaining hopefully for
most of you it'll be at a pace which is
kind of about right and you be like okay
this is making sense I'm getting a new
idea and the questions are sort of
appropriate to my level of understanding
okay if I'm doing my job well however
even if I am doing it as well as I can
just looking at this class right we have
a broad range of skills so there will
always be some of you who are kind of
like I know this already or come on can
you hurry up and get to the interesting
part and there will also be people who
are like I don't understand anything of
what he's saved right now like I I know
about all of the words individually mean
and then you put it together and I you
know I just thought getting any of it
but everyone else seems to be quiet
it seems to getting it so I'm just gonna
shut up and work it out later right
and so we stream classes like we grade
you guys when you put you in you know m2
or m4 m6 or whatever in order to try and
gather together the people who are like
similar ability but you guys can see in
this this class we've got a broad
spectrum right and by the way not only
like I know which a few other people who
were kind of like and I don't understand
what's going on not just because I know
you guys I've been teaching for a while
but I can see it in your eyes like this
is sort of glazed-over look that you get
really like yes I've done this topic or
this topic is completely meaningless to
me so I can tell and it's it's sort of
sad for me not just like I'm a failure
as a teacher but like it's it's you know
I feel bad for you guys being in that
position because I remember what it's
like being that position and it's not a
good place to be
either is the first problem the second
problem is with regard to homework right
I said in theory number one it just
doesn't happen right like half the time
it doesn't happen because I know how
busy you guys are you got a million
other subjects and commitments you have
to do and even though like the idea is
yeah every night I do this and this and
this I feel like the reality is probably
more like maybe twice a week you get in
a good session on on one particular
thing right and then a couple of days
will pass you just got to do the other
stuff I mean you might have a better go
back and do something wish solution
that's or whatever and not only that
even when you're doing it you create me
from wrong book when I'm doing an
exercise and try to work something out
that's when I need help that's when I
need someone to talk to but
I'm actually doing the question and I'm
like ah now I know that I don't get this
whereas what I'm sitting listening to
someone explaining right if even if I'm
sort of at the right pace it feels like
here I understand this this all makes
sense right and then you try and do it
and that's when you realize you need
help right which is why most of us don't
ask questions when an explanation is
going because when someone's telling you
something it sort of makes sense because
it comes from someone who seems like
convinced that it you know it all fits
together like yeah I kind of get it it's
only when you do the exercise you
realize you need help right but you're
doing the exercise at home and you're
mostly detached from where you detached
with me you might you know your my
message of freedom stuff like that but
it's not the same as actually just
sitting with someone trying to work it
out so this is two problems now here's
the idea right what if we take the
normal way of doing things right explain
at school do exercise in the stuff at
home and turn it around the other way
okay so what you do is at home you you
look at all the explanations and you try
and wrap your head around the concept
right and then at school you come and do
the exercise okay now because of that
kind of switching idea teachers and
educators and fancy people who write
research articles that kind of thing
they call this the flipped classroom so
it's it's turning it upside down that
makes sense okay it might anyway so my
question to you guys is we're now in the
position where we could give this a go
some people actually in them in the u.s.
this is a really big thing and what
teachers might actually do is they'll
spend all summer which was in July which
was me but anyway there's been all
summer you know I'm worried looking at a
video camera and I doing all these
explanations in preparation for their
classes coming back and then when
they're actually around then they want
you to Hoonah like okay
oh and I thought about that idea and I'm
like I I don't have you know the time or
the inclination to do that on my own
okay that's why I do that you know what
I was doing in class but now because we
come full circle we can actually do this
right so here's what I want you to write
down here's my thinking process and I
want you to help me through it okay
I'm trying to think about whether we
should do an experiment right and give
this a go okay now just on the on the
blank side of the paper okay follow
instructions Chloe you on the place and
the hyper the black side of a because
man what you do just leave it where it
is I want you drop's Yukons the two
columns are pros and cons okay pros and
cons now I've done some thinking and
I've done some reading about this so
what I'm gonna do is what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna walk you through some of
the pros and cons which I know about
this idea okay but I need your help in
like you've got a different perspective
and you know different IP different
years I want you to help me think of
more so I'm just gonna get you started
okay and then I'll get you to turn over
that piece over and fill the rest okay
so what are some advantages to this idea
the most obvious one is even if I told
you the whole arm right the explanation
plays not for the right pace for
everyone right so if you're watching a
video unlike me you can pause and play
and rewind and replay as much as you
like when you're watching a video right
so that's kind of like okay I know what
this is about
I'm just gonna skip the next ten minutes
okay or I watch this makes no sense to
me but I feel bad to ask a question to
class so you can just go back and watch
it as many times as you like right or
you like this was three months ago and I
can't remember so I can go back okay so
there's there's a big advantage I also
said you know there's a problem of when
you're doing the exercise that's what
you need help right well if we spend the
majority of our time in class actually
doing exercises I am always accessible
to you you can boys out of any you guys
are accessible to each other and that's
just sort of it frees up that time if
that makes sense
okay so it puts the time where you need
the most actual person-to-person help
when there are people around
another advantage if we're not spending
like a lot of this time when we spent
the class is just you listening to me
right which is you know not necessarily
the best way to do things so if we push
that to another time right then it frees
us up in class trip for me to do
consultation for us to do more kinds of
examples right so I might run through he
is one kind of question let's do five
examples right but there might be 15
examples that are really worth yeah but
I just don't want to talk in you that
long we just don't have the time of
class physically to do it I'm
particularly with some of the more
challenging examples right so freezes up
to do more of those kinds of things well
that's part of what I'm trying to work
out I'd assume yes assume yes but I'll
get onto that one disadvantage a third
advantage that I've I've been doing that
for a long time that I've wanted to do
for a while is if freezers have been
crossed for you guys to actually get up
and explain stuff okay now at university
right at university you go to lectures
and you go to tutorials okay so it's
kind of like splitting apart they
explain it explain teapot and the
exercise part into two right now
lectures you get the the professor or
whatever and they explain all the stuff
and in tutorials you often have to ask
groups you have to work out stuff and
explain it and do pre presentation and
so on I always hated it in tutorials
where like you're 13 weeks of class and
like the first week is introduction and
then 12 weeks ah
okay I'm gonna pay you guys off and you
guys do the presentation I was always
like are you kidding me I'm paying like
thirty thousand dollars and you're
making me do that this is rubbish like
what am I paying for you're paying me I
mean you to explain to you that this
just feels dumb and I'm like you know I
always felt like the tutors half a time
will make us do this because they didn't
know what to what to say so I'm like
yeah I'll make those guys do it and then
I know
I gotta work now hopefully you guys did
well enough and I've proved like in
person and through the videos that I'm
not doing this because I don't actually
know the material what I honestly
believe right as a teacher I know it's a
funny thing I'd love you even
contemplate this but I always used to
think you know how I can't be to be a
high school teacher because at least in
our country everyone's been to high
school right so you know all the stuff
so you just have to get up and talk
about it right but any of you guys
who've ever tried to explain something
to someone else know that that's a
complete lie because you need to know
something number one very thoroughly
number soon in a in a deeper way to
actually explain to someone effectively
than if you just want to know it enough
to answer a question okay so I actually
think I'm doing you guys a big favor by
forcing you to get up and try to explain
a concept because you will understand it
much better yourself okay it's an idea
right so there are a bunch of pros okay
they're just the ones that are
comfortable in here okay cons there are
disadvantages okay one of the things
I've hated as a teacher often we get
taught or you know here's this new
educational idea and it's gonna solve
all your problems and your students will
all get people whatever or no and it's
always exaggerations there's always like
a kind of give-and-take that they always
tell you the giver they never tell you
they take your leg actually does this
costs it so example watching a video
even if it's me standing up in
explaining something is not actually the
same as me
standing up and explain to you because
I'm not I'm not making eye contact with
you you can't ask me questions if you
want to one of the things that people
from other classes have mentioned
particularly the for you guys because
they don't tend to get 3des material
explain to them because they're too busy
to be there for your stuff is I've said
ah because I actually sat down with
someone after sport and they were asking
questions I'll stop you it is like ah
this is really weird because when you
watch your video you have to get used to
not asking questions because you can't
ask questions
so even though salt we don't tend to
make a habit of that it's kind of nice
to be able just stick up your head and
say well the way this explanation makes
their sense to me right and it's a
problem in an explanation because
suppose 15-minute video right and the
thing you don't get is 60 seconds in
right and the other 14 minutes depend on
you understanding that first minute and
you're like but I don't get it and I
can't stop someone and say well I can't
just say that a different way so those
14 minutes and whatever subsequent you
just I'm stopped okay so that's a
disadvantage there's just gonna be
technology issues that come up like you
know or whatever my cord are or just you
choose playing off today or something
like that and I feel very very
frustrated if the reason we can't
explain something do something
everyone has to be able to do is because
technologies now I think I think that's
most of what I was going to say oh we're
not a disadvantage is that when I'm
talking to you
even if I'm really boring I'm kind of
the only thing in the room whereas if
you're watching YouTube right yeah
there's plenty of other things there
there's Facebook that is open all of the
related videos are there on the side
that some of them are really really
funny way I'm sure you know the computer
is a distract it's actually it's a pro
distraction environment right it's
designed for that very purpose to be
able to do many things at the same time
okay which is not necessarily conducive
to actually learning from what you're
watching so it's not with us to say it
disadvantages okay so that's that's what
I've come up with now I only wanted you
to write them down so that when you turn
em and fill it out you don't say the
same things that I've said and current
member what was the second thing I said
like six minutes ago so please turn over
to Page now and I'd like you to span
final six minutes thinking and feeling
this out as honestly as you can because
I want to know your your thoughts on
this yeah
well yeah I guess so so but I'm just
trying to temper it against the fact
that went up to meet you you cost me you
really can't ask a question you can ask
it right down and also as a teacher like
one of the things that I'll do on any
given concept I'll know four or five
different ways to explain right but I'll
only pick out one or two unless
someone's having trouble and then I can
pick out three four or five and that
might be the one that makes it click for
you right so I can do that better in
person
I can engage better the answer is what
you think is nobody
Wow I just thought now by the way that
the answer the question - sorry question
three actually sort of these the acidic
ocean theory is critically important to
me because there's always a big
difference between what you might think
is going to happen and then what
actually happens right so I want you to
all this is answer as honestly as you
can like yeah like yes or no whatever I
want you to try and predict and then I
want to see how that like we're gonna if
we do this but if all of your feedback
is overwhelmingly negative then I will
not do it because I know I can teach
normally and it will go okay right
whereas this is kind of going out on a
limb so I went but if we do try it
I will assess it at the end with a
similar kind of forms